cata greets cristian cásseres with his
news now briefing in spanish
on monday businesses will be able to receive
up to 50 percent capacity
due to the order the
governor signed last month public gatherings will
also increase to a
space for 250 people  while
some businesses such as clubs both
day and night will remain closed
at least until the first of may and i
heard this the cosmopolitan expects you to
be the first on set to reopen his
law firm wicked spoon prepares to
welcome the public on 25  March, they
ask you to make a reservation and
limit your stay to only
two hours. Cosmo was one of the
last law firms to close, doing
so temporarily in January, and starting
Sunday, pharmacies and Diesel Evada
will offer the
coronavirus vaccine for  those
eligible people they will give the doses of
modern ifai be only you can
make an appointment starting tomorrow at 1  0
dot com or in the application decided and
for those people who do not have
access to a computer
there is also a customer service line
for more details
news now dotcom diagonal in Spanish and
we turn to the weather forecast
we will have temperatures reaching 50
degrees for  Today the rains will continue
for the rest of the day and yet
a hot weekend is expected I am
Cristian Cásseres with his brief
news now in Spanish Happy
Friday
[Music]